قالت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان ممثلين
عن القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع بداوا السبت محادثات تمهيديه في
جده وقال البيان ان المحادثات تهدف الى
وضع جدول زمني لمفاوضات موسعات تتيح وقفا
دائما للاعمال العدائيه بالسودان كما تهدف
الى تسهيل وصول مساعدات انسانيه طارئه الى
السودان واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه وقال
بيان الخارجيه السعوديه ان الرياض وواشنطن
حتى طرفين السودانيين على الانخراط بجديه
في المحادثات كما حثى الطرفين السودانيين
على الحفاظ على مناخ ايجابي للمحادثات
التمهيديه في جده وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني العميد نبيل عبد الله قال
للجزيره ان التفاوض يبحث اليات تمديد
الهدنه ولا يشمل اي اتفاق نهائي لوقف
اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه